OK, so here we have our data. And from cell A1, if we push Cmd down, or on a PC
I believe it's Ctrl down, then we see that there are 8,702 students. So first
let's calculate the average. So again, equals. Average, cell a1 colon a8,702,
enter. So we get that the engagement ratio is about 0.077, if we round to the
nearest thousandth. Okay, now that we have the mean, let's figure out the
standard deviation. And we don't use a correction when we're treating this a
population. So first let's find the square deviations from the mean. Equals a1
minus $d$1. To keep this mean constant. Because otherwise if we just put D1 and
then we copied this cell for all of column B then it would subtract D2 from A2,
and then D3 from A3, and there's nothing there. We want to always subtract D1
and then we'll square this quantity. So there's are first square deviation.
We'll copy this, Cmd+C or Ctrl+C. We'll go to cell A8702, go to B8702, Cmd shift
up arrow key. All of column B is highlighted. Cmd+v. Now we have all our squared
deviations. Now let's take the average square deviation, which is the variance.
Equals average B1 colon B8702. So here's what we get for variance. And now for
standard deviation we'll take the square root. Equals sqrt D2. So if we round
the standard deviation to the nearest thousandth, we get 0.107.